in this segment we will go through two
examples of maximum likelihood
estimation just in order to get a feel
for the procedure involved and the
calculations that one has to go through
our first example will be very simple we
have a binomial random variable with
parameters N and theta so think of
having a coin that you flip n times and
theta is the probability of heads at
each one of the tosses so we flip it and
times and we observe a certain numerical
value little K for the random variable K
and on the basis of that numerical value
we would like to estimate theta
according to the maximum likelihood
methodology the first step is to write
down the likelihood function this is the
probability of obtaining this particular
piece of data if the true parameter is
Theta
now since K is a binomial random
variable the probability of obtaining K
heads in entosis is given by this
expression here so what we need to do is
to take the data that we have observed
plug it in this formula leave theta free
we have here a function of theta and
then maximize this function of theta
over all theta let us now do this
calculation actually instead of
maximizing this expression it's a little
easier to maximize the logarithm of this
expression and the logarithm of this
expression is as follows there's the
first term which is the logarithm of the
n choose K term then the logarithm of
theta to the K is K times log theta and
finally the logarithm of the last term
is n minus K log of 1 minus theta so we
need to maximize this expression with
respect to theta in order to do that we
take the derivative with respect to
theta here there is no theta involved we
get a contribution of 0 this term has a
derivative of K divided by theta and
this term here has a derivative which is
n minus K
time's the derivative of this
logarithmic term which is 1 over what is
inside the logarithm but by the chain
rule because of this minus sign here we
get also a minus sign and we obtained
this expression now at the maximum the
derivative has to be equal to zero and
this gives us now an equation for theta
that we can solve let us take this term
move it to the right hand side and then
cross multiply with the denominators to
obtain the relation that K minus K theta
this is obtained by multiplying this K
with this one minus theta factor has to
be equal to this term times theta which
is n times theta minus K theta the K
theta terms cancel and we're left with
this expression which tells us that
theta should be equal to K over N so
this is the maximum likelihood estimate
for this particular problem which is a
pretty reasonable answer if you would
like to rephrase what we just found in
terms of estimators and random variables
the maximum likelihood estimate tour is
as follows we take the random variable
that we observe our observations and
divided by N and this is now a random
variable which will be our estimator now
notice that in this particular example
the answer that we got is exactly the
same as the answer that we got in the
context of Bayesian inference when we
were finding the maximum a posteriori
probability estimator but for the
special case where the prior was a
uniform distribution so if we assume
that theta is actually a random variable
but has a uniform distribution so that
we have a flat prior and we carry out
maximum posteriori probability
estimation we do obtain exactly the same
estimate and this is consistent with the
comments that we made earlier that
maximum likelihood estimation can be
interpreted also as map estimation with
a flat prior
let us now move to our second example
which will be a little more complicated
here we have n random variables that are
independent identically distributed they
all have a normal distribution with a
certain mean and variance but both the
mean and the variance are unknown and we
want to estimate them on the basis of
these observations the first step is to
write down the likelihood function that
is the probability density function for
the vector of observations given some
set of parameters because of
Independence the Joint Distribution of
the vector of X's that we have obtained
is the product of the PDFs of the
individual X's of the x i's so the PDF
of a typical X I that has variance V and
mean mu is of this form so this is the
likelihood function in this case this is
the probability density of obtaining a
particular vector X of observations when
we have these particular parameters we
would like to maximize this function as
in our previous example it is actually
little easier to maximize the logarithm
of this expression and this is the same
as minimizing the negative of the
logarithm of this expression now when we
take the logarithm of this expression we
have a product so we're going to get a
sum of logarithms and I leave it to you
to verify that the negative logarithm of
this expression is of this form plus
some other constant that does not
involve the parameters and which comes
from this factor of 1 over square root 2
pi in particular this term here appears
when we take the logarithm of this and
this happens n times because we have a
product of n terms and this term here
appears when we take the logarithm of
this expression and after we put in the
minus sign
were actually considering the negative
of the logarithm now to carry out the
minimization what we need to do is to
take the derivative of this expression
with respect to MU set it to zero and
also take the derivative with respect to
V and set it to zero as well
solve those equations and find the
optimal mu and V so let's start by
optimizing with respect to meal so we're
going to take the derivative of this
expression with respect to MU and set it
to zero this term does not involve mu so
we only need to take the derivative of
this and the derivative of this is going
to be there's a term 1 over V and then
the derivative of the quadratic divided
by 2 is just X I minus mu and we have
one term for each possible i we get this
equation now we can cancel out V and
we're left with the equation that the
sum of the x i's is equal to the sum of
the Meuse which is n times mu and now we
can send n to the denominator to obtain
that the estimate of MU is going to be
the sum of the x i's divided by n so the
maximum likelihood estimate of the mean
takes a very simple and very natural
form it is just the sample mean now let
us continue with the minimization with
respect to V in order to carry out that
minimization we need to take the
derivative of this expression with
respect to V and set it to zero
the derivative of the first term is
equal to n over 2 times 1 over V and
then from here when we take the
derivative we obtain the sum of all
these terms
/ to v-squared
but actually when we take the derivative
of 1 over V the derivative is minus 1
over V squared and for this reason here
we will have a minus sign so this is the
derivative with respect to V we set it
equal to zero and carry out some algebra
what is the algebra involved here we can
delete this term - that appears here and
there this term V cancels out this
exponent here then we take this V move
it to the other side and then take this
N and move it to this side underneath
this term and finally what we obtain
after you carry out this algebra is this
expression that the estimate of the
variance is some form of the sample
variance where we use the value of the
optimal value of MU and the optimal
value of MU we have already found it's
given by this expression here so we
obtain a pretty natural estimate for the
variance as well by using this maximum
likelihood methodology now these two
examples were particularly nice because
the algebra was not too complicated and
the answers turned out to be what you
might have guessed without using any
fancy methods but in other problems the
calculations may be more complicated and
the answers may not be so obvious